IEIN VALDEZ: Hi.
I'm Iein Valdez, a developer
advocate with Google.
And I'm here to talk to you
about Google App Engine.
App Engine helps you build
your apps, whether you're
building an app in the cloud,
on Python/Java/Go, you're
building a mobile application
with Android or IOS, or you're
going to build an HTML5
or Chrome Web
App/Extension, or even Dart.
So the traditional approach to
application development has
been painful and cumbersome.
You've had to manage machines,
figure out how to get a
database running,
scale your load.
And at the end, you don't really
spend a lot of time on
your users.
So App Engine is easier.
We help you run your apps on
Google's infrastructure.
We make it easy to build, easy
to maintain, and easy to scale
your application.
And we give you everything
you need.
So we have a local SDK.
In Java, Python, Go you can
download it, install it on
your machine, and get up
and running quickly.
We have a series of powerful,
managed APIs for data
persistence, queues, everything
you need to get
your app up and running.
We also have our fast,
secure cloud runtime.
So once you get the app
built locally, you
can deploy it quickly.
And we have the admin console,
where now you can manage your
application and make
changes to it.
Some of the core features of App
Engine, we have a series
of compute services you can take
advantage of, frontends,
backends, task queues, cron.
This is where you're going to
process your web requests.
We have a bunch of storage and
persistence mechanisms from
our non-relational datastore
to cloud SQL, as well as a
high performance in-memory
cache called Memcache.
We also have a series of
services and APIs that you can
take advantage to manage
your users, image
manipulation, and so forth.
So what's special about App
Engine is that you, as a
developer, can focus on
being productive.
We give you the SDK.
You have near zero
configuration,
no servers to manage.
And it's an application platform
where you can build
your app and make it
very powerful.
It's also free to get started,
and you only pay
for what you use.
App Engine's ready
for business.
We're a fully supported
Google product now.
We have 99.95% uptime SLA.
We have paid support.
And we also have a series of
platform certifications, so
you have confidence that
your app is going
to be up and running.
There has been tremendous
developer momentum.
As of January this year, we have
over 100,000 developers,
300,000 apps, and
we serve over 3
billion daily page views.
And you can take advantage of
that with your application.
There are four different
categories that we see these
300,000 apps fit into.
And you can probably think
about where you fit here.
So we have our mobile,
tablet, HTML5 apps.
We have social, mobile games,
consumer web apps where you
have to handle unpredictable
traffic and scale, as well as
business applications.
So what will you build?
Come visit us on
appengine.google.com, and let
us know how it goes.
Thanks.